we are starting a new channel this week
Monday two days from across tomorrow we
should have winds ability hurdles or in
our mind I done broke my neck we have a
big announcement for you we are starting
a new channel
that's right Nico got tighter the other
two making a third one which great
pleasure I finally can announce that
we're starting a podcast we are going to
be shooting this for an hour every week
and you'll get to watch we know a lot of
really interesting people don't mean to
break their the years of doing the
corridor channel we have met a lot of
really interesting people it really
hasn't been a way to share them with you
now we have a chance to share all those
interesting people we know with you
through interesting conversations
interesting questions interesting
discussions and I share one thing that's
great about podcasts is that they are I
would say they're the best combination
of the the promise of the Internet and
social media with public forum
communicate information without all the
baggage and standards of old media and
stuff like that so we really really like
how that's shaping out right now and we
want to be a part of that by starting
this podcast it's really deep way too
deep that's way too heavy delete the
clip this was the podcast I could I
could explain myself even further so you
have to go there to check it out leo and
video so you can listen to it on your
favorite podcast staff that's all good
but you can also watch it from done here
where we are live editing and cutting
and have video of everybody there's
gonna be both audio and video for
however you like to consume your podcast
the corridor cast the corridor cast
right now head on over to youtube.com
slash corridor cast is linked in the
description there's a little card thing
that probably popped out at some point
right here and go and subscribe right
now they're already four episodes lives
Carlos we have Mike Deva
we have Jake Grover with vsauce3 best
one of all
founders podcast just me and Sam telling
you all the juicy details and you never
got to know here on the corner crew
channel youtube.com slash corridor cats
I'm being summoned yo it's been like a
month maybe you longer so we put a video
on the quarter channel and we need to
get another and hopefully two videos up
before Christmas break um hurry because
right now has nothing in the can we
don't chew anything like this week that
means nothing comes out until like end
of January people subscribe not go to
three months without videos I mean if we
get some scripts in hand I can start
kind of planning and get things going
maybe for the next week or sometime yeah
two clips video and say she's Sam's
video Friday okay this week thank you
Monday two days from the props tomorrow
we should have winds ability hurdles
would you rather fight one horse-sized
duck or one hundred duck-sized horses
we're doing that video so go there's no
neck brace like that's it you've been
given two scoops for two videos like you
shot spur have to shoot this week
yeah scripts and shot lists time so you
gonna suggest reading this by Wednesday
but I don't know how our Wednesday might
be a little an Wednesday so vicious
I'll see Mike I'm troubleshooting hard
right now man I'm working on this duck
sized horses oh I have to animate one
hundred duck-sized horses running
through the hallway I've been
troubleshooting all morning so there's a
lot of CG a lot of stuff that I don't
know how to do that's awesome because I
perforce myself to do it there's only
seven VFX shots in this video it's way
less than an enemy soldier in cars every
every shot in this video requires some
sort of custom animation
the Internet I would like I'm ready
spotlight slow zoom on the darkness and
then you see a duck they'll come out of
the darkness into the spotlight
round - all right cut like I have two
precious pull bandages I see you're
driving your comedy from the fact that
that's so ridiculous and you're gonna
try and make these ridiculous things
real yes which is gonna be funny I think
in the plum nail you don't want to just
see ducks and horses I think you want to
be hitting one of them like I want we
need to know that this is about combat
you want to at least get a taste of
combat because that will decide our
conclusion the problem with that and the
reason why that's currently not in there
is because that does add complexity to a
video that's already on a tight time
constraint I think the video is great I
think adding one shot of the dude kickin
horses and then flying up is doable and
for the leave it at that
talk about the actual production
logistics here sorry we shut off all the
lights tape up the exit signs and that
gives you pretty close to pitch-black
and then we'd have to figure out getting
the 120 d
and the ceiling another after agent yeah
hey Steve how you doing trying to see if
we can get the I'm pulling Lander ass if
by chance Sybil has a key to the ladders
you do if we don't get this ladder it's
gonna complicate our shoot
[Music]
good stuff time to listen to a whole
podcast you just hop on over to
youtube.com slash forecast click on a
couple of the clips that we've picked
from the episodes that you might find
interesting and catch a minute or two of
Harley Morenstein talking about there's
a whole element of gaming the system
that goes on like before this podcast
even started like Nikko it said if
there's anything weird if you say
anything weird that you change your mind
later you know let me know we could pull
it out and I didn't want a podcast with
Tay Zonday he said the same thing to me
and whenever I did Epic Meal Time videos
I would say leg 2 people if we say
something or do something that you don't
like let me know and I'll pull it out
later whereas in this day and age people
are so keen and so quick to expose one
another in exchange for viewership we
don't have that this is a new thing
we're doing it's not changing anything
else we're doing you're gonna get all
the same corridor crew videos you're
gonna get all the same corridor videos
we're gonna be working on bigger
projects but this is another little
endeavor that we're going on and we'd
like you guys to come on this adventure
with us stay tuned later this year for
our fourth channel where we cut things
in half with a guillotine if you want
Steve to talk about smoking marijuana in
the 70s if you want Logan Paul to talk
about 40 million dollars in merchandise
if you want Ethan in hilla to talk about
their baby head on over there leave a
comment yeah-oh
I mean from what I understand he was
pregnant he was
placing Eli you don't pronounce the H
silence I was just three three all right
yeah I think we've we've probably we've
done the job here so bats in the belfry
to Lux leaves and batteries they both
[Music]
ideally with the Stinger quit though man
just play an overall plan for the day
shoot this stuff out here in the hallway
get all that stuff done and then so as
soon as we're done with we just move
into here shoot out this stuff we're
gonna need like four I realize white
hands less shirtless yeah sweet ever
know what's going on
I could switch one of these Lexi's from
V lock the gold mount will be sick
that's our mo all lights should be on
gold amount and all of you lout
batteries are for camera Department okay
we want to go spot Jarrett I don't want
him out there on the ladder by himself
the issue with that spot which is what
we're going with is that it's gonna
bounce off the back wall you might see
the back wall
but the issue hanging out here is you
see these doors the plan is to just hang
it up here and deal with seeing the back
wall if anyone can figure it out it's
you Jerry yeah the janky way of doing
all this work if we had to take our
talent it would be so easy no found the
longer screws to all those different
colors
[Music]
is everything running smooth Clinton
yeah things are smooth clean it's been
attacked by a hundred duck-sized horses
and so we're doing cuts all over his
body and then we're putting band-aids on
each one of those cuts after the shoot
clean we'll have to take all the
band-aids off see look like oh my god
why are you putting it on my beard this
is clearly not enough band-aids guys
dude I'm going what do you mean you guys
need upgrade I've heard it was really
bad from some people I'm really good
from other people it was really good
really good
you are gonna generally make our days
you're gonna finish everything in our
location one in the hallway we were
supposed to come inside and finish the
very end scene of the piece with this
little lab setup here with these
computers in the door but don't think
we're gonna have time for that so we'll
do it tomorrow
luckily tomorrow was already a prep day
for another video so I'll take an hour
out of that day shoot the last thing so
we got it done in a day Dana Dana little
chunk so not exactly what we plan for
but still doable I'm hoping this guy's
playing music again so I could dance to
it for you
it's gonna give you a great shot but
okay we were worried that we're going
slow which is always the case on a film
shoot but we're going alright
it's me after apparently you have to
shoot stuff tomorrow too now yeah we're
gonna have to do a bit anyway it's
almost six o'clock you know what we
start at 10:30 we should be running
until you say but this guy's house
playing the beat again we danced for a
second just playing this great like
pokey
still finding it he's still finding the
creative things that always stuck out to
me the most was when I went in for the
surgery the big one and I remember
feeling all the paperwork and they asked
me like who had power of attorney
basically like if you don't wake up from
surgery like who has the authority to
pull the plug or not right there's like
oh that's the thing that I've never
considered yeah and like my girlfriend
at the time was there I was like hey
would you mind like doing this for me
and I had like lay out the rules okay so
if Ike I'm in a coma for this long like
then you can pull the plug if I like
this head it's like all this stuff and
I'd like write a will which I'd never
considered ever after right now cuz I
was in my twenties like what the hell